baby mama cover fors got these other
Travis Scott denies cheating on Kylie
Jenner baby okay moving on according to
a report the rapper postponed a concert
in New York on Thursday to instead be
with Kylie after she allegedly accused
him of cheating but a rep for Travis
tells et that's simply not the case
quote Travis Scott vehemently denies he
cheated on Kylie
it is not true he did not cheat he
cancelled one show tonight because he is
under the weather
that's not Union twisty it's been a
month full of drama for the
kardashian-jenner fan
et has learned Kylie's longtime best
friend Jordan Woods moved out of Kylie's
house after reports surfaced that Jordan
allegedly hooked up with Khloe
Kardashian's man
Tristan Thompson a source told ET quote
Kylie is extremely upset about
everything that is going on with Khloe
and her best friend Jordan Jordan is a
sister to Kylie and she's extremely
shocked this could happen as is the
whole family I don't know it's just not
cool as for Jordan she'll open up for
the first time about the alleged
incident on Friday's episode of read
table talk with Jada Pinkett Smith the
models decision to go public with her
story hasn't exactly gone over well with
the famous family according to a source
the Kardashian's feel Jordan should be
focusing more on healing her
relationship privately you have to find
the happy medium of keeping your private
life private and you personally you know
it's just we'll see